[Music]
and mile-high Fight Club new freshmen of
Fight Club Wow
they still got cyclone okay I think so
submitted by Gio loves McDonald's yes
true okay uh moving on
oh wait 2015 we go how'd you get a clown
on a guy for that it's true and thank
you very much thank you very much chair
American Airlines suspended a flight
attendant after an altercation over a
stroller oh I heard about this one I did
hear about this one I did I did can you
talk like that all the time for you hear
about this one the slime sure about this
one second
that's probably what you heard what I
heard was it both ways forward everybody
was on the ladies fight but through
investigation it turns out she's a [ __ ]
that's what I heard was this a real
fight now a hair pulling and all that no
no but mama let you tell the story
though cuz I don't know the groups y'all
so heard why no I'm not why did it so
much scandal with the airplane these
days I know and then just like this is a
crafter we hear about the United side
and I will make my own airline because
that's what mr. Virgin America did
middle of Branson Charles was a great
Charles Branson Richard Richard Branson
I'll seek in a Charles Manson
Peter Gregory screamin Jamaal Ian Ayre
oh well you could get lost up in
shortfalls tamale air Jamali air Oh
Mar 20 million right so this whole thing
was an American Airlines flight from San
Francisco headed towards Dallas so there
was this unnamed Argentinian woman who
was carrying twin 15 months old already
sounds like a bad business why don't
they just say one-year-old 15 month old
likes it because their 1 1
one year three months I'm with you
though because I hate that I never
called Isaac like oh he's 17 months like
I said you're like oh I'm 21 and 3
months how could there's people who go
ridiculous like how's a kid 82 months I
know I'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] is that a to
learn about 300 month year-old there
should be a cut-off after 12 right times
I with you but they're reporting you
could see my class to be specific so
much you talk too much
old good well I know carrying her 22
month old right so she was holding one
on her hip and the other one was sitting
in a chair near her and so when she was
boarding the plane she had a double-wide
stroller and she was trying to bring
that stroller into the airplane angle it
on all your dumb [ __ ] no you can do
that right yeah so yes we rather
Correctional Center those laws of
eyeballs you don't even need a measuring
tape again I clearly for you because
it's it's like it's not common sensical
you know like the aisle is like this and
then [ __ ] the the strollers having
two chairs side-by-side like I wouldn't
even give me this goddamn chair oh [ __ ]
off you pregnant [ __ ] like you may
follow the movie it involves moving
chairs in the hospice I wouldn't write a
book if I said yeah I would move one by
one
yeah so I picked me up so rude to the
laws of eyeball make sense American
Airlines hiring what are your [ __ ]
Reaper sir United hot dragged your ass
up all I hear her stroller was tags for
it to be taken into cargo right and so
usually what the procedure is is like
with bigger strollers they take that
stroller when you're at the ticket
counter but in this case I guess they
let her keep it
all the way up to the gate and so
usually when people have strollers and
they'll give it to people right when
you're boarding students and so she was
trying to see the stroller into the
airplane
there was miscommunication of some sort
and
so what's being reported is that this
flight attendant allegedly was being
really violent towards her timing like
wrestled a stroller out of her hand and
so in that altercation he almost almost
yeah yeah he almost hit the baby that
was on her hip so that's like what this
whole is gonna mellow happen and so I'm
going to show you guys the video of the
aftermath and I don't like the real
Kuzco
exactly we will we don't know unless we
were witnesses you see the argument yes
so then we're going to view is the
aftermath of that whole altercation and
then there's a passenger that stands up
trying to defend this woman and in that
flight attendant the one that caused the
altercation gets in the man's face and
then okay let's see what happens
sorry who's that the mom out of mana if
you fish you find even I can't tell or
does the baby remain show you out
who's asking her for the water cleansing
call she's nice
so this woman is a witness telling them
suspect that the man was violently
threatening her mom who hasn't been
thinking it he's asking for the name of
the man that did that always count on
white people to help I need to know the
information so I can report this to the
manager I'm going to report this to the
symptomatically
you can always count on why I'm able to
help though they'll stand up and help
help you if they see that you're in
trouble this is not appropriate so
here's what you're saying I he grabbed
the stroller violently and I guess
they're explaining to her like well she
can't bring the stroller in and the
witness is saying I understand that but
you can't be that violent it's also not
the UFC either it is that guy the pilot
that they're complaining - he looks like
a pilot yeah I think so yeah he's got a
white shirt in a lanyard he's a pilot
you got that [ __ ] thing on the side
of his shoulder there is this is a man
hey okay but you do that to me and I'm
trying to get me a nice bike you know
what story his mouth I like it so here
keep looking I'm going to show this what
you did that ladies love it keep it
quiet hottie how you supposed to do it
though he got that nice elbow follow him
he points the elbow first and then fro I
like that dog that's how you're supposed
to argue in a peaceful manner because
like I swear if it was like a bunch of
hood people it would just be [ __ ]
fist everywhere but he was like you need
the whole story final quiet cuz I should
I felt it though hit me hit me
stay out of anything I gotta learn how
to do that yes it's very that's I
supposed to do it we always make fun of
it but that's how you suppose you don't
freak anyone out
no violence happen well you get the
point across yeah cut oh you know how
the whole Tommy yeah fine gunshot I'm so
curious what's the full story then we
hear inside her sighs his eyes hey well
what was up with the guy that came out
of nowhere the Savior guy he witnessed
the whole thing so you're saying I want
to know his name personally she thought
- yeah yeah everyone there's also enough
he was just disgusted by the guys
managed exactly so American Airlines
responded wences video went viral and
they said close we have seen the video
and have already started an
investigation to obtain the fact what we
see on this video does not reflect our
values or how we care for our customers
we are deeply sorry for the pain we have
caused this passenger and her family and
to any other customers affected by this
incident that's how you apologize though
that's a better apology than a United
one and then they continue with the act
of our team member captured here do not
appear to were select patients or
empathy to values necessary for customer
care in short we are disappointed by
these actions oh that's how you supposed
to do it so how do you two Mama's feel
if someone were wrestling a stroller out
of you would you guys like okay would
you get it with your partake in the
wrestling down and get violent or what
you dressing I want to have a baby in my
head you don't put the baby down um no
we're watching your baby now
I think y'all should take baby
martial-arts no that just sounds like an
ego tackle oh because all right imagine
I got a baby here so how you gonna send
off a bad guy with a baby your babies oh
no should we have one baby in arms in
arms yes cute yes definitely something
else Jillian's your other baby she's too
big too babies right baby martial arts
get the [ __ ] away from my stroller walk
away from my you kick hi I just hope
that their heads just stick to the front
kicks okay I feel like that's you and
your foots gonna get caught your snatch
your baby under the floor but not again
I guess like when I see it as I don't
even think you two would even get to
that point because you would've been
intelligent enough to say these two
strollers are not enough to explain and
then after they tell you it's not going
to fit on to play I don't think I would
struggle to try to bring the stroller
onto the plane like after somebody of
authority with like ma'am it doesn't fit
I don't care I'm still gonna bring it on
so the way they handle it completely
wrong yeah but also lady you have two
[ __ ] kids was it worth it for you to
try to bring something on that they
already told it doesn't fit and you
don't need this stroller in the air but
it's like you're going to go up and down
this aisle and my thing too like I think
there's responsibility on both parts too
like if you have two kids on with you do
you think it's smart for you to try to
wrestle it away from somebody think
about your kids that's how I see it
anyway how are you holding two kids
we'll start like fighting for a stroller
not in one one another one was next to
it because I just don't understand the
mechanics behind that definitely how
like the the guy handle the situation
was terrible there's you people and
around I mean
anyone that goes stay out of it buddy
you continue to go downhill
stay out of it buddy do something hit
anything either
could be bad yeah I knew I liked that so
what happened after the woman was
escorted off the plane along with her
kids obviously and the airline upgraded
the woman to first-class for the rest of
her trip so she was planning on doing a
layover in Dallas and heading to
Argentina so for the rest of her trip
she got first class
nice Internet I need to just get in a
fight with the airlines and I'll get
free upgrade their fault you know when I
when I first saw his video I kind of
laugh not because of the situation
because she was crying attitude she
cried more up soon as people started
like I'm so like for me it was cut I'm
not saying that she wasn't crying but
then I was like I never person I cry
like Oh what kind of an example are you
showing your little babies they're
watching you right now mom was a little
[ __ ] this looking crazy they're gonna
go up to know that like you could cry
get away and be a little [ __ ] in life
as soon as that baby's born you are an
example this I [ __ ] live baby little
baby so then once the woman was escorted
off the flight they allowed that flight
attendant to resume his post for that
flight heading towards Dallas because
it's not like it's always we couldn't
leave yeah exactly so the Union force
license like they actually praised him
for that fact the fact that he still see
on the plane he still did a job cause he
could've easily just been like okay well
you know walked away and then that
flight would have been grounded and then
all the passengers would have had to
wait until the neck there another flight
because then they would have had a
backup flight attendant to attend that
flight so what they're saying is after
this ordeal and after he completed that
flight the flight attendant was
suspended and so the woman also did get
a full refund for her flight club a one
first-class plus a $1,000 voucher oh my
god can I have how did she fly first
class with two babies on the same chair
probably the other baby had first-class
seats next to her and she was holding
the other one
and I did the baby blue coach she's like
huh thank you so much [ __ ] just get in
the back so bad I'm sorry lady the same
lawyer that's representing dr. Dow from
the United this [ __ ] trying to
make money now dude representing her now
she's just looking for he's probably
just looking for any type of airline
[ __ ]
and he's like first to hit him up on
YouTube with his YouTube account now
it's like airline lawyer 555 that's this
[ __ ] like I should honestly in her case
I don't think you need to be represented
you got reimbursed the whole airline
apologize you got a thousand dollars
what else I know what emotional distress
emotional distress we puppies up her I
don't think she should shoot you sooo
good it's a personal issue with him and
that guy has been resolved I know but
the lawyer got involved now which is
that not but not for money to dr. green
a lot of people are gonna do I know is
but it's wrong those it's going after
greetings that are justice because they
apologize really well they gave her all
these cars hot you know be an adult and
say who we both apologize that was a
misunderstanding and it didn't escalate
to the point where she was being dragged
and beaten dr. Dow situation is way
different I mother he got looked up dude
he fell asleep on the plane to kill me
to kill by duck tail boy real yes
hey guys thanks for watching our last
episode did you love it I know you did
so make sure to give this video a big
thumbs up and to watch more videos you
can watch them up with you
[Music]